[Music]
yet what you pay for
alright I kind of looks like your hair's
sneaking up behind no it's okay I was
trying to get away back there The
Apprentice I was watching The Apprentice
oh really
yeah I was watching the apprentice and I
thought I want to get a little
information so I hit the info button and
it said archival footage of America's
final president look at this one I was
watching preseason football preseason
football and I hit the info button and
it said watch your UPS guy almost make
the round so I'm watching the CBS
Evening News okay I'm just checking out
the CBS Evening News you see what's
going on I hit the info button it says
greetings nursing home staff
yeah I was watching the show Boston EMS
yeah Boston EMS and then I just I hit
the info button and it said this is the
show for you if you want to hear
paramedics say heart attack
I decide okay a dating naked I was
watching the show dating naked yeah I
love that show and then I hit the info
button and it said watch people who
aren't brave enough to do porn
yeah devious maids if you watched
devious maids they are devious oh-ho
devious maids yeah I hit the info button
it said you know that dusting that was
supposed to get done turns out it might
not have her outside Pawn Stars Pawn
Stars I was watching Pawn Stars I hit
the info button the title is a play on
porn stars and that's where the sexiness
has bones I was watching the show bones
I hit the info button said we know what
you're thinking is that show still on
but this is the wrong question your real
question should be isn't time a man-made
construct why do we quantify it as
something tangible and finite
shouldn't we be grateful when we find
the anchors to more our cosmic boats in
this sea of temporal uncertainty and
bones is the girl right
[ __ ] I mean and finally bachelor in
paradise
yeah bachelor in paradise watching it
for a bit then I hit the info button
what so paradise is the name of a drug
store that carries valtrex
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography